sir you know I'm a big fan of your work
I I it's great to talk to you today
thank you very much thanks a lot
um before I get into 65 uh you are one
of my favorite hosts in recent memory of
Saturday Night Live I love wow thank you
we all everyone at collider loves your
episodes so what I want to know is what
do I need to do to get you to join the
cast for a season
uh I you know I don't know
a lot of coffee and donuts that's uh
I'll do mostly anything for that right
can you host again soon have you spoken
to Lauren yeah there was maybe one but
then uh no you know if it came up I
would I would totally do it again it was
uh
uh a lot of things going on at the time
but I I love uh of doing it and the the
cast and the writers of that thing and
Lauren is is great so it's it's always
uh yeah yeah it wouldn't take it
wouldn't take much I I like I like doing
them okay I'll leave it there and just
say I really need it to happen your
episodes are great oh thank you very
much I I know that you get offered a lot
of scripts so what was it about 65 that
said I need to do this or that it was so
unique and that you know it was a you
know big blend of a lot of different
things it was dinosaurs and laser guns
and space uh ships crashing and it
didn't seem like some uh rare to get
asked to do that but then also that that
is kind of ancillary to it being a movie
that is really kind of a father-daughter
movie and it was trying to you know
anytime that
there was a big scale movie big scale
family movie that uh you know that every
everyone can go to that uh you know
doesn't let the spectacle get in the way
of two characters that hopefully are
three-dimensional and as it was about
grief and I I kind of got it in the
first thrust of covid and as I'm sure
many people did were obviously making
the connections of what was going on in
the world with what this you know
scriptures reading but uh the idea that
it was about two people from a
completely different you know background
facing this you know obvious threat that
no one had a precedent for that seemed
you know uh and through that become you
know found family based on this common
thing of grief and him denying uh
because everything that he sees in her
reminds him of his own daughter and he's
denying that feeling as much as possible
until they can't anymore it seemed like
a unique thing to do in a big scale
movie like this let's be honest it also
allows you to fight uh you know
dinosaurs yeah yeah
yeah after the T-Rex I really didn't
care I was like who do you want me to
play sure that's interesting so long as
I get to battle a T-Rex and shoot a
laser gun but I mean isn't that a little
bit like you're
into like your inner five-year-old or
seven-year-old when you're standing on
set with that gun and you're getting
ready to fight yeah or your inner 39
year old I I yeah I mean Jurassic Park
for me the first one watching it in
theaters was a big you know seminal uh
moment and you know you know it's it's
dinosaurs and T-rexes it's like it's
great you know like a hundred
percent
um I'm just about out of time with you
but as you know um I am a huge fan of
Coppola and you get to work with him and
I just have to ask you what has it been
like getting to work with a master
filmmaker I have to say with no kind of
um uh I just I've wrapped it last night
my part of it I like I I had I'm
operating on two hours of sleep we uh I
finished it there's they're still going
but it has been one of the best without
hyperbole or best shooting experiences
of uh my life you know watching him work
that crew that that the design team you
know he has such a command over you know
cinematic language and an archive in his
mind of of uh shots that are so uh
beautiful and doing something so
ambitious and on his own on his own
terms that you would think it would be
uh dictatorial or really controlled but
he is the most uh warm open thoughtful
uh director who you know is just you
know
he really and this all sounds like
general you know being very general but
he he really embodies this thing of like
we're making this experiment
and we're not interested in how it comes
out we're interested in the process of
making it and inevitably because of that
the thing that you make there's no film
reference for you know I think what he's
made is so unique
and interesting I couldn't be more uh
proud to be a part of it I am so looking
forward to this movie I cannot put into
words how excited I am because he's
spoken about it for so long yeah yeah
and you would think that it would be and
I've had this experience before with
another filmmaker that they've wanted to
make for a long time you would think it
would be I know what it is like do this
and uh go and that would have been that
would have been fine but that it was
that he gives you so much uh
uh control and and uh you know license
to kind of you know work with you know
uh not not only like kind of
disregarding the the 35-year history to
making the movie but being really open
to what's happening now is is really
rare I I'm not finding all the right
words because I'm over tired but uh but
it was it was incredible and I I think
that what what he's made is so visually
stunning but not but for such a big
audience that uh I it's hard it's hard
to describe which is what's exciting
about his films listen man it's great to
see you and I'm so so um happy for you
um have a fantastic day thank you